a couple of weeks ago internationally
renowned cognitive athlete
kirsten gillibrand also us senator
announced to the world that
everything is infrastructure presumably
even her bridge abutment
we're saying well sandy cortez saw this
and thought you know i need my own big
idea
and so she came up with one and here it
is according to congresswoman cortes
everything is climate change the climate
crisis
is a crisis born of injustice and it is
a crisis born of the pursuit of profit
at any and all human and ecological cost
which means that we must recognize in
legislation
that the trampling of indigenous rights
is a cause of climate change
the the trampling of racial justice is a
cause of climate change
because we are allowing people and we
are allowing ourselves
to make sure that we are allowing folks
to deny ourselves human rights
and deny people the right to health care
the right to housing and education
so obviously the worst thing we ever did
in this country was give bachelor's
degrees to dumb people especially dumb
aggressive people
that's what you get mark stein isn't
originally from this country she's got a
clearer picture of this he joins us
tonight to
assess it turns out mark that climate
changes racism is indigenous rights as
infrastructure it's all bad give me
power that's my read on it but you know
i'm not great at textual analysis what
do you think this means
yeah everything is infrastructure
infrastructure is climate change climate
change is racism
racism is everything you you said i
think it's about something
ibrahim ex-kende had been saying that
you rolled your eyes your reaction to
this is to roll
your eyes my reaction is to roll my eyes
i would be happy to pitch
uh a an eye-rolling hour every night on
this channel for these kinds of stories
but the fact is
that nobody who matters rolls their eyes
at aoc they all take her seriously
nobody laughs even people who have a low
cunning
like chuck schumer who isn't an idiot he
may be
depraved in certain political senses but
he's not an idiot
and he knows and he knows that he uh he
can't
he can't go up against this you know and
i found myself when
when i first saw this story i was
thinking well this is this is actually
pretty uh
ridiculous because for example you know
uh racial justice well what does that
even
you know the the transatlantic slave
trade
reached its height during the little ice
age
uh which was also when the french and
indian wars occurred so there appears to
be
no correlation at all between uh
racism and climate change uh between
indigenous rights and then i thought
what the hell am i doing this is rubbish
this is supposed to be this is supposed
to be science
i've been in a 10-year lawsuit in
washington dc up against the guy who
invented the climate change
hockey stick and he's a scientist and
his position is that
uh in the last millennium nothing
happened for nine centuries
and then you tucker got into your suv
and fried the planet
and that's a completely idiotic theory
but at least he's not trying to sell
uh the world on the idea that somehow
climate change correlates to racism
when you get to this stage it's not long
before the planes start
dropping out of the skies because people
are going to be
well you know we need to uh we need to
hire some pilots who
uh recognize the uh the racial injustice
in in flying planes
this is if everything is racism nothing
is racism if everything is
infrastructure
nothing is infrastructure infrastructure
is racism and racism is climate change
that is all
ye know and all you need to know
they're destroying any incentive for
anyone to engage in reason or measured
debate
all they do is is scream things that are
demonstrably untrue and it works so
maybe we just respond
every time someone says we don't like to
scream you're a criminal you belong in
jail
and just repeat that long enough and
maybe it'll come true i mean who wants
to live in a place like that where
that's
that's the level of public conversation
well exactly and and
i i said that you know you laugh at this
and i laugh at this you know the people
who really laugh at this
uh chairman xi and the chinese politburo
because they don't have to bother
thinking about any of this and it frees
up all the
the remarkable amount of time to talk
about something
important and something true well that's
so nicely put as always mark stein thank
you so much
thanks a lot tucker